a third term for Turkish president
Richard erdogan economic problems at
home and balancing East-West relations
are just two of the Urgent challenges he
faces so what does erdogan's re-election
mean for turkey and for the wider world
this is Inside Story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program I'm
fully batibo it went to a runoff after a
very tight first round but Richard has
emerged as a clear winner of turkey's
presidential election after overcoming
probably the biggest political challenge
he's ever faced he will hope his third
term will further tighten his grip on
power opponents have expressed dismay
with the poll results starkly reflecting
deep political divisions in the country
a key player between East and West
turkey is relations are complex such as
the NATO member also being on good terms
with Russia we'll be exploring what
erdogan's re-election May mean for the
country shortly but first Hashem al-bara
in Ankara tells us what some of the most
pressing issues are
now that he has been re-elected and
secured a comfortable majority of the
parliament the next five years will be a
defining moment for president
but he will continue to face a wide
range of issues such as the economy
which has been declining over the last
few years and on this many experts
expect a return to economic Orthodoxy
where he should give the Central Bank a
give a say in the future he will also
need to rebuild the entire cities
devastated by the earthquake something
which is going to cost him a hundred
billion dollars to do that he will have
to build Bridges with the U.S and the EU
his ties with the International
Community have trained over the last few
years but he is giving indications that
he is willing to mend offenses
particularly when he ratified finland's
bid to join NATO widely seen as a sign
that he wants stronger relations with
the West in exchange for more financial
support to be able to fix the economy
and to rebuild the cities that were
devastated by the earthquake president
erdogan told his people that now he's
looking forward to move forward
and unify everyone who voted for him or
voted for the opposition we'll have to
wait and see whether he will be able to
deliver on all those promises for Inside
Story
Al Jazeera
well let's take a closer look at the
challenges president erdogan faces as he
begins his new term in office Turkey's
economy is in crisis with its people
struggling with a High Cost of Living
the Turkish lira has lost nearly 340
percent against the U.S dollar during
the five years of President erdogan's
last term and inflation is running at
more than 50 percent critics blame
erdogan for refusing to raise interest
rates the President also faces a huge
task of uniting a deeply polarized
Nation the opposition has criticized his
government for its stance on Syrian
refugees erdogan has accused his rival
of siding with Kurdish Fighters that his
party regards as terrorists millions of
people in the southwest of turkey are
still living in makeshift homes after
two devastating earthquakes in February
president erdogan has promised to
prioritize rebuilding in those areas
now with erdogan's Victory turkia's
foreign policy is also in the spotlight
NATO members are hoping Ankara will
allow Sweden into the military Alliance
turkey has blocked Sweden's application
erdogan says the country hasn't met all
of turkey's demands turkey is described
as the bridge between Europe and the
Middle East but its relations with
Russia have unsettled Western Powers it
has close ties with Moscow but also
provides military aid to Ukraine
turkey's foreign policy over the years
has expanded its Global influence it's
intervened militarily across the Middle
East Africa and Europe last year Ankara
Health broker a deal that ended Russia's
blockade on Ukraine grain supplies
[Music]
thank you
well let's bring in our guests now for
today's Inside Story in Istanbul is
Helene sari artem associate professor of
international relations at Istanbul
medicine University in Peterborough is
Ben Harris founder and editor-in-chief
of bne in tele news and in Istanbul as
well is Ono erim political advisor and
president of dragoman strategies a warm
welcome to all three of you thank you so
much for joining us on inside story anur
in Istanbul let me start with you please
in his victory speech president erdogan
called for Unity and solidarity with 48
of Turks voting for change
how is he going to unite such a
polarized country will he extend an
olive branch to the opposition
well I mean uh his uh Speech which is
now known to be as his balcony speech uh
did start with uh you know expressions
of that he will need everyone's support
and everyone coming together to achieve
the goals of the The Next Century as as
he pretty much you know labeled uh
turkey as next model going into the
second 100 Years of uh of the Turkish
Republic
um as far as the the numbers that he has
gotten
do realize that in the last two
presidential elections 2014 and 2018. uh
this is not much difference except for
maybe a decimal or two for erdogan the
52-40 split has been there at least
since 2014. how is he going to bring
those 48 percent of Turks who didn't
vote for him on board
well first of all the first two rounds
the first two times there were no second
round there were no runoffs uh I mean
the first one the second one wasn't Hey
listen he has been battling perfectly
against everybody in Turkey all the
entire opposition which are uh which are
you know they're like day and night most
of these guys that got together under
College almost candidacy they got
together just to get rid of erdogan I
think he was battling against everybody
else he's still in the first round was
able to uh you know surpass by more than
almost more than five points which is
pretty much about four points now more
than 200 close to two and a half million
votes just over 2 million votes this
time so uh I don't necessarily I don't
know if you can call that polarization
uh you know because most of the
presidential races in countries with
presidential systems this is basically I
mean you would probably consider this a
landslide if it was in the US okay so it
stops yeah Helene what are your thoughts
on says this isn't a country that's
polarized necessarily and that President
erdogan Victory is a decisive one it is
decisive if it's not polarized uh it do
you share that point first of all that
this is not a polarized country and how
does erdogan unite Turks today
oh well it is a polarized country
unfortunately and this trend is a global
Trend so turkey is not the only example
in which polarization is getting higher
and higher we see the same Trend in the
United States we see a similar Trend in
most of the European countries as well
inside their own societies actually
people are trying to decide about the
Fate about their faith about their
future way of living and in in terms of
this perspective we see that Turkish
Society is somehow split into two
because one side is quite secular and
liberal and the other side is quite
conservative as well as nationalists we
have seen and witnessed a huge rise of
Turkish nationalism
especially in this last couple of fix in
the first and second round of the
presidential elections and especially
president erdogan's
policy for this election was mainly
based on uh Turkish nationism I'm not
sure whether the help of the Turkish
Society I mean the opposition part is
feeling
themselves as Turkish nationalists that
much because the narratives that the
erdogan and his party that erdogan and
his party is using is mainly taking its
route from history from ottoman past
from the concurrence of Istanbul from
the past coup d'etat in 2060 so it's
mainly about a conservative past as well
as a very Turkish nationalist past okay
before I bring in uh Ben into the
conversation oh nor I'm going to allow
you to respond to what Elaine just said
and also ask you about what president
erdogan is going to be now towards his
policy is going to be towards the
nationalists and he reached out to them
during the campaign of course is that
Trend going to continue
well you have to realize his number one
supporter politically is the uh the
Nationalist MHP party who's the second
oldest party in Turkey he has been
collaborating with them under the same
Coalition for at least six seven years
and there's all the indications that he
will continue so I don't think there's
going to be any difference in approach
as far as he's concerned his policies
are concerned when it comes to you know
feeling uh very close to uh now of those
nationalist views and as I said uh I
think polarization is is really mistaken
in Turkey as opposed to anywhere else uh
people here the the as soon as the race
is over the elections are over people
just are going about their ways let's
not uh you know mistake the the wars
going on in social media uh between the
the parts or or the polarized Parts as
they call uh with the regular public
more than half my family is extremely
opposed to uh to erdogan a lot of my
friends are we have no problem with this
is when you talk about polarized
political size in Turkey I don't think
it's the same thing as most outside of
outside of 2K would understand to be so
let's get Ben's thoughts on this Ben do
you expect now a much more conciliatory
tone and approach from president erdogan
now that the election is over will he be
more focused on uniting the country
I don't think so I mean erdogan is um
All About power and if you watch his
career um as he rose uh set up the ACT
party and that has just won his party um
but that was based in uh Islam
conservative values and we've been
talking about here polarization I think
is better to describe it as a divided
country and it's symptomatic of its
place uh in Europe I mean right on the
edge and half the countries looking East
to to the Arab world and the other half
is looking into Europe and
um I think it's notable that you know
erdogan has led this this sort of uh
conservative Islamic nationalistic
tainted campaign
um whereas the opposition the Republican
people's party I mean this is the party
of Ataturk they're the founder of the
modern State and it was very much he
committed turkey to to uh liberal um
secular State we my correspondence uh in
turkey box pop young people uh young
professional liberals and they're
looking to the uh to the West they look
into Europe and many of them said that
if a country continues to go down this
increasingly conservative path that they
would lead they would upsticks and go
and I think that's the issue here is
that it's not polarized so much it's
divided between these two different
ideas of where the country should go and
the country just voted in erdogan which
means it's going to go down that more
socially conservative more religious
orientated line than it had done before
the reconciliation is trying to bring
those two parts together
um it doesn't they don't really fit
right okay so two two different ideas
you say Ben of where to take turkey let
me come to you now on or and talk about
the immediate challenges domestic
challenges that President odawan faces
and that is of course the struggling
Turkish economy one of them the main one
what are we going to see in terms of
Economic Policy will we see a U-turn
from president erdogan on some of his
more controversial economic policies to
deal with the skyrocketing inflation
wow you could say a lot of things about
President erdogan uh one thing you got
to give him though he's he's a he's a
leader he's a political uh figure that
actually is keeps a very good beat of of
the of the public of the uh of the
citizens so if he has to change things
around if he deems so he will he will do
it right away right now it's no of
course secret that the Turkish Academy
has been under heavy fire you know
especially from the West uh and that it
has been you know it has its own issues
that that's been going along going along
for a long time but the thing is uh
despite all of these despite the uh the
big war right next to us despite the
troubling economy in in especially in
Western Europe which is our biggest
export partner and despite the fact that
the USA is really struggling financially
I think turkey is holding its own pretty
good now how long can can we can we last
and how long can he can even get point
we will have to see but for sure he's
definitely has definitely promised for
better days economically for the entire
Turkish population better days
economically are we going to see him
change his policy on on these low
interest rates
I don't think so okay I don't think so
and he's actually and and the and and
there's a lot of uh you know despite the
the very heavy uh you know media against
him on this uh there's actually a lot of
papers coming out as it has been before
uh try you know maybe questioning what
he was doing was wrong while everybody
was Raising interest rates for him to
lower the interest rates but as I said
this is a uh this is a very debatable
issue I could go on for hours and hours
let's let's hear from Ben who wanted to
jump in on that Ben what do you think
about the economic policies well we see
him deviate from these uh unorthodox or
some would say unorthodox policies he's
had on the economy uh
and Orthodox is is a massive
understatement uh he's convinced he said
in an interview with Bloomberg that if
you lower interest rates the central
bank then you bring inflation down which
flies in the Orthodoxy because it's the
other way around and you mentioned uh
the turkey's got 50 inflation and we
think those numbers are highly massaged
and that it's much higher and yet he's
reduced or the central bank has reduced
interest rates by 500 basis by five
percent
um which is insane so the currency has
gone from three Lira to the dollar down
to 20 now and the analysts are saying
that there's going to be another now the
elections are over and now the the
central bank is going to let go of some
of the controls because it has to
there's only another 25 evaluation and
at the same time
um the reserves have virtually run out
because they've been trying to hold the
lyrics stable before the elections and
at the same time turkey's running a
whopping 50 billion dollar a year trade
deficit and this is all answers
sustainable so turkey is headed or is in
a massive economic crisis already it's
just not manifested yeah Haley and they
are indeed concerns at the Turkish
Central Bank can't continue to prop up
the Lira president odawan has said he is
the one who can deal with this economic
crisis do you believe that
well we can I think assume that the
Turkish society as the majority of part
of it uh actually both this statement
and uh underlined their support for
erdogan that he is the one who is going
to solve every kind of problem and as
well also we also have to understand
that the most of the society also thinks
that yeah the economy is bad we have
problems but at the same time he is the
cure so opposition couldn't
change this idea about erdogan there's a
huge Trust on him as a strong man and we
also have to underline that the big
cities are different from the other
local parts of Anatolia and the main
parts of the woods are coming from
Anatolia small cities local places in
which the people are not suffering as
much as those people living in big
cities regarding the high inflation
regarding the high rent and so on for
that reason we can assume that President
erdogan's main support is coming from
Anatolia not the big cities Metropolitan
Metropolis like Istanbul Ankara and
Ismail there are there will be problems
there will be a hard time ahead of us
everybody accepts that the only
difference between the opposition and
erdogan support is that the the people
majority who are supporting Ardon are
ready to suffer much more just to save
him as the leader because most of these
people are also thinking that this is a
kind of a western game being played
against turkeys High inflation is a part
of this uh
anti-turkey rhetoric right as president
Trump in the past for example he used
the sentence that he has the the ability
to play with Turkish economy just with a
tweet for that reason many of the people
are thinking that this is actually a
responsibility of the West and
is the right person okay okay before we
talk about what we can expect on the
international stage I wanted to touch on
the issue of the Syrian refugees and
honor come to you about this uh
president erdogan has promised to send
back one million syrians over the next
few years is this feasible is this
possible or was that just campaign
rhetoric
he actually said he will set the stage
uh a livable Humane stage for a million
people to go back to Syria and as it was
uh just announced I think a couple of
weeks before the elections uh there was
a deal uh or a collaboration I should
say rather made with the state of Qatar
to build uh you know housing and and and
all the social surroundings of it uh for
for a million refugees to go back to at
least the the uh the controlled and the
safe part of Syria so yes he said he he
never used the word he will send them
back he always is very careful about
that he said he will set the stage and
give all the uh necessary make sure that
all the necessary things are done for
them to go back willingly and that's
really the difference between erdogan
and everybody else Ben your thoughts
about the issue of Syrian refugees
presumably the Europeans are happy that
erdogan is still in power because he's
been able to deal with the Syrian
refugee crisis and perhaps not allowed
The Refuge is to get into the European
Union how how do you see this evolving
now that he's been re-elected
well he's he's been very pragmatic he's
been using it uh as a card I mean the
reason why the Europeans were happy that
uh they didn't turn up in Europe was
that the Europe paid billions of dollars
in order for him to keep them and in
that sense he's become very
transactional in a lot of his foreign
relations uh he's become transactional
about what he can get out of it and he
uses the issue of the refugees as a card
that he can play in order to extract
concessions from Europe in the form of
cash
um in the Middle East there's a
Reconciliation going on rapidly at the
moment that um Iran and Saudi Arabia
have just mentioned fences after nine
years of non-diplomatic relations and
the same thing with Syria itself has
just been readmitted to the Arab League
right and so here he is these million
refugees
um that zakari can play with that and I
think he's going to be very careful
about it but he definitely because of
his relatively poor relations with
Europe in the sense that he's been
trying to get you he's never been able
to do it but he's also looking to the
east the Middle East as well in order to
who has the upper hand right now Ben
sorry to interrupt you but who has the
upper hand now in the relationship
between turkey and the EU and is he
still interested in getting to the
European Union given the strained
relations we've seen
well he's he I mean they were granted in
what was the late 80 89 and 1999 giving
candidate status and they've been left
in the waiting room ever since and I
think he said in 2017 he's basically
given up on it because Merkel herself a
German chancellor stood up and said
turkey will never get it so I think it's
clear it's not but
EU remains a major Market
um and turkey is very interested in that
so he wants to maintain those good
relations but at the same time there's
not a line thing going on that's being
led by China and Russia and he's also
interested in doing that and I think I
think he sees himself in the middle of
the spider's web with good relations to
the West relations to the east yeah and
he and good relations with the Middle
East as well so I mean again Refugee
issue is a card to play in that game
okay Helene let me ask you about the the
relationship now with the East and West
president erdogan has got one foot in
NATO but he's also got one foot turned
towards Moscow towards Russia is this a
position that's tenable in your view
yeah this will continue and this is in
total harmony with turkey's traditional
foreign policy approach it's a balancing
act since the very beginning of the
Republic for that reason especially in
the last couple of years we observed
that erdogan and his party is uh going
through a kind of reproachment with many
of the neighboring countries including
Syria we are getting closer with Egypt
with the gulf countries with United Arab
Emirates Saudi Arabia even Greece in the
west and this approachment will continue
because this is quite beneficial for
turkey
economically we need this reproachment
with the neighboring countries and as
well as this also this is a very
important to improve turkey's soft power
which was lost to a great extent with
the increase of the heart power
especially in Syrian Civil War I also
expect that there will be soon there
will be a kind of a handshaking between
arduan and Assad in Syria and I think if
turkey can manage that and the problem
of Syrian refugees and refugees will
also be sold quite clearly quite easily
by sending them back after a
reproachment with the Assad regime okay
uh honor Elaine says she expects a
handshaking between erdogan and Syria as
Assad very soon what about the
relationship with Washington DC and NATO
also I mean one of the point of tensions
with NATO has been turkey agreeing for
Sweden to join the military Alliance do
you see that happening and how does the
relationship with Biden now move forward
well I'm just making throwing a little
little fact to a previously made to me a
very unjustified uh comment that turkey
is being turkey is being made look like
he that she is uh sort of using this as
a card against Europe to get money uh
turkey only received just over six
billion dollars from the European Union
uh in in exchange turkey has spent more
than 45 billion dollars on the Syrian
refugees so to call Turkey uh holding
this as a stake against Europe to get
money is is first on based and secondly
very unjust uh going back to what
happens with NATO well I guess when you
say nato you really talk we're really
talking about the United States I don't
know buy the message aside no one has
really come up to date as to why Biden
and to a degree Trump in his in his last
uh a year or two was so hostile against
Ricky no one has really come up with an
answer or an explanation as to why cure
care was not delivered the F-35 said it
was that it that that she paid for or no
one was able to explain why uh turkey
was asked from the F35 program uh you
know once as single-sidedly without any
reason and against all the uh you know
contracts that has been signed so I
think uh what happens next uh between
the relationship to the the
turkish-american relationship really
depends on how the how Biden
Administration uh and the and the United
States government acts I think the
burden is upon them to make the next
move what about uh the session of Sweden
to Nato uh or nor will president erdogan
now accept to ratify Sweden's secession
now that the election is over
look it's no secret that these are
mostly uh political decisions but right
arduan puts you know in in the beginning
put a very straightforward you know uh
statement out there that the
international recognized terrorist
organizations they do something about it
uh that he will he will continue and if
they don't if they you know continue to
Harbor these terrorists who are you know
maybe some are not accepted as
terrorists every some everywhere but
some are erdogan said he will not move
but saying having said that I do
understand that these are more political
decisions than anything else okay Ben
I'll give you the last word and allow
you to respond to to owner who was
saying that it's not right to call
turkey's relationship with the EU
transactional and also get your thoughts
about on uh the future of the
relationship with Washington and Russia
at the same time
well complicated issues I mean I see
it's transactional in the sense that you
know with the issue of Sweden's
membership of NATO the the turkey rolled
over and accepted Finland straight away
um but as my colleague was saying you
know there's these um the Kurdish um uh
People's Party the pkk uh and they a lot
of those uh guys who have taken refuge
in Sweden and elegance made it very
clear that you need to Aid lift the
sanctions that were imposed on us um
about five years ago NB you need to
extradite these guys um who we claim or
believe or see as terrorists um Sweden
went as far as putting through a new
terrorist law which comes into effect on
June 1st and my understanding of it is
that uh Ankara is waiting to see the
effect of that and whether if any of
these guys are pkk guys are expedited
back to Turkey before he goes ahead and
takes off the um agrees to NATO's
um agrees to to note Sweden joining NATO
as for Washington I mean yeah the the
issue with the fighter jets the US made
fighter jets has also been a um a thorn
in the side and haven't been sent but
again that's part of the the problem
with that was it was scuppered because
erdogan agreed to buy this s 400 uh
anti-missile system from Russia which is
non-nato and the Americans took great
exception to that and this is what's
ended up as a between those two things
and it's example both of elegant playing
both sides is also an example of him
wanting to develop his own military
capacity and not be totally dependent on
NATO and Washington in that sense don't
see turkey as a team player although as
part of the alliance and is it again
sits in the middle playing both sides
every time
um and this is what is in a lot of
trouble we we're gonna have to leave it
there obviously there's still a lot of
ground to cover in this conversation but
we'll leave it there for today thank you
so much to all three of you for joining
us on Inside Story Helene sari artem
honor Irene and Ben Aries thank you and
thank you as well for watching you can
always watch this program again anytime
by visiting our website at aljazeera.com
for further discussion go to our
Facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash AJ Inside Story and of
course you can join the conversation on
Twitter our handle is at AJ inside story
from me fully batibo and the whole team
here in Doha thanks for watching bye for
now